a quinnipiac university poll now gives
president biden the lowest mark since he
took office
his approval rating plummeting to a
dismal 33 percent and those surveyed
also gave him a thumbs down when it
comes to handling the big issues of the
day the economy foreign policy in covid
plus the headlines
not kind to the president
they warn about his stalled agenda and
highlight the fears the democrats now
have about the upcoming midterm
elections where the party is in danger
of losing
control of congress
yet the president doesn't seem to be
changing anything about his strategy
especially when it comes to covet just
moments ago a short time ago he vilified
people who have chosen not to get the
vaccine again
i've been i've been saying that as we
remain in this pandemic
this is a pandemic of the unvaccinated
and i mean by this right now both
vaccinated unvaccinated people are
testing positive
but what happens after that could not be
more different
if vaccinated people test positive
they're overwhelmingly have either no
symptoms at all or they have mild
symptoms
douglas when you hear facts and people
come back with something that doesn't
quite fit
like
we know that whether you're vaccinated
or not you're exposed to omicron you're
hoping to mitigate that mitigate that
with a vaccine the president instead
just keeps poking the bear and and
pointing fingers at people making the
decision that they've made
that's right by the way i'm i'm
surprised he's making as good figures as
he is in the approval ratings at the
moment 33 i'm surprised that's terrible
i'm surprised he's i'm surprised he's
riding that high wow i mean this is a
president who apart from anything else
has been dodging the media dodging
accountability
uh for months now
in any other democracy this wouldn't be
acceptable you have a commander-in-chief
who will not answer basic questions
about his decisions
uh he his views and his his policies
don't get a chance to get gone over by
the media i mean most other democracies
don't work like this you know the
president would get held accountable and
he just repeatedly makes statements
incredibly inflammatory statements
incredibly inflammatory speeches like
the one earlier this week
and there's no accountability and you
know he said remember his great pitch uh
for becoming president was that he was
going to be the great unifier and that
his predecessor had been the great
divider but he has kept using speeches
and statements such as he makes them to
divide america still further look at the
stuff on voting reform this week it was
basically either you're with me or
you're a nazi
you know is that the talk of unification
you know uh kaylee last hour on the
faulkner focus i i counted four times
where
unification was where people were teeing
off on the president and i hear it again
from douglas now
and
it's almost like we need to hear from
the president
on who he wants to be now because who
he's presenting is completely
oppositional now to who he said he was
going to be in office which i guess is
why senator mcconnell says i don't know
who that guy
was yeah he gave his inauguration speech
and used some version of the word unity
like half a dozen times
this is the most divisive president i
have seen in the last two decades
especially when you look at the numbers
when you drill down into them that
quinnipiac pole the left-wing pole he's
decided to pivot to division i agree
with douglas murray that speech that he
gave was one of the most divisive i have
heard saying if you oppose the
federalizing of elections if you oppose
it you are essentially a segregationist
uh meanwhile his vaccine messages the
unvaccinated have a right to be angry at
the vaccinated this is division division
division and americans are noticing it
because in quinnipiac asked is he
uniting us or dividing us 49
said dividing 42 said unifying so
americans are recognizing the strategy
and i hope the administration's
recognizing the five-alarm fire they
have on their hands with quinnipiac
left-wing polling organization who said
andrew gillum was going to be the
governor of florida he's not it's ron
desantis but that poll left-wing poll in
my view showing 33 percent approval i
was stunned when i saw that and had to
double check the numbers that's a 505
alarm fire it's going to invite primary
challengers and probably more than one
if i had to guess kayleigh just to
quickly um kind of double down with my
questioning on this because i am curious
when do you really start paying
attention to pulling i mean you've been
in the white house before so you know
yeah maybe one or two maybe a couple of
months i mean this has been a stubborn
slog in the numbers for this president
for months now
yeah anyone who says they're not looking
at the polls in that administration and
biden has said that uh is deceiving you
they are looking at the polls what you
are seeing is absolute panic in the
white house that's why they're
desperately trying to get something
passed on the hill it's why they're
pivoting to this voting rights agenda
that is just sewing division and the
messaging that they're creating it's
getting worse and worse for them they
say they're not looking at polls harris
take my word they are looking at the
polls how could you not with 33 approval
you know emily
when i think about what the
administration and the white house and
the president should do next in terms of
meeting these numbers with a message
i am
confused
conflicted about what that message
should be like where do you start
yeah exactly i mean
to be honest i don't know it's sort of
like walking into an abandoned falling
down haunted house and you're like i
don't even know where to start with a
renovation but you know what harris who
cares with the exception of the fact
that this is our commander-in-chief who
is absolutely reprehensible in the
dereliction of duty let's just put that
aside for a second because the
republicans are coming for him and
that's the strong messaging that's the
unified messaging that people are
following so for example the national
republican campaign committee they
reported that this year they didn't just
break records of fundraising in an off
election year they blew it out of the
water they report a 17.9 million haul
just last month they brought in over 140
million dollars in 2021 and that's just
not in the macro in the micro sense for
example kevin mccarthy he brought in a
whopping
11.70
million dollars in donations and
fundraising in just quarter four 72.4
million dollars this cycle so here's the
thing
regardless what the democrats think that
they are doing and the messaging the
confusion that they're putting out in
the media the things that they think
people care about
americans know what they care about and
that is putting food on the table job
security safety at our border safety in
their streets and protection to earn the
livelihood that protects their families
and those are the things that are
lending them to put their money where
their mouths are and that's with the
republican party right now yeah the the
chairwoman of the rnc and i talked this
week about those numbers and if you saw
tammy just a few or tommy excuse me just
a few moments ago kevin mccarthy at the
lectern talking and a news conference
about what really should be the things
to focus on as emily just laid out i
mean you only raise more money when you
promise to actually come up with
solutions to all the crises that are out
there i would imagine
and i do believe contrary to everybody
else in the panel i do believe that joe
biden is a great unifier i believe that
he is unifying not only republicans but
i believe he is unifying the american
people against this woke do-nothing
agenda of his administration i think
even the most leftist of the lefties i
think that they are starting to see the
light and that is why democrats are
panicking democrats are also coming
together and unifying against this
president as i've said before on this
program i believe what is going to
happen and we're already seeing it is
democrats are going to distance
themselves not only from joe biden but
from kamala harris they're not going to
distance themselves from the agenda
because it is their agenda to begin with
but they will distance themselves from
joe and kamala because they're going to
make it seem like those two are the only
problems you saw that was stacey adrian
abrams just the other day she probably
has aspirations for 2024 we're even
seeing it with al sharpton coming out
and criticizing joe biden democrats are
going to attempt to gaslight the
american people into believing it is
just joe and it is just kamala but it's
more than that it is their agenda it is
their party that is the problem and the
american people as a whole republican
and democrat would do well to remember
that in the midterms and especially in
2024 you point out something that is so
important just in terms of looking at
the landscape ahead and that is the fact
that it is their agenda and he's not
carrying the flag the way that many
would want look we're still waiting to
hear back from fair action that that
political action committee by stacey
abrams to see what conflict on her
schedule would be more important than
the key issue for her and a visiting
president we haven't heard back from
frankly anything would be more i'm not
holding my breath on that
um but you know you bring up such a
great point tommy just in terms of how
they plan
down the road who can you count on and
who can't you count on apparently not
the people in the white house douglas i
want to give you the last word
well i mean i'm just you know stunned by
this because as i say you know we're
short way into this presidency and it's
been unraveling from the get-go the
question now is how much worse can it
get and when the point is the democrats
realize how far underwater they are and
start to try to change things but it is
not going to be easy for them hi i'm
brian kilmeade i want you to do me a
favor i want you to click to subscribe
to the fox news youtube page this is the
only way that i know for sure that
you're not going to miss any great
commentary any great news bites any
great interviews coming your way on fox
you can get it all here on youtube so
subscribe right now